it's not often we get to use the word
remarkable around here but we can use it
this time because we're going to begin
this hour with a remarkable love story
more than 60 years in the making here's
how it goes Caroline Reeves and Eddie
lamb there they are they were high
school sweethearts in Nashville
Tennessee in the 1950s look how she's
looking at him they broke up after a few
years she's still looking at him they
broke up after a few years and didn't
see each other again until just over a
year ago Eddie is now 85 now he's
looking at her looking at each other I
love this Caroline turns 82 on Thursday
and as our lead National correspondent
that would be David begno found out they
recently married and guess what they are
still very much in love
it was 1956 Elvis was playing on the
jukebox Ike and Mamie were in the White
House and Caroline and Eddie well they
were in love oh I just thought he was
the cutest boy on campus you know and
once I saw her it was all over Eddie
lamb was earning 65 cents a day
delivering The Nashville Tennessean the
newspaper that would one day tell their
love story when I took her out all I
could do was coke and french fries and
that was about it that's the only meal
he ever bought but it was fresh french
fries with a Coke known around town is
Eddie's Girl Caroline Reeves wasn't
looking for a fancy dinner she had her
eyes set on his high school class ring
and all that it would signify it was an
engagement ring and I was the type of
person
that would have committed myself to him
for the rest of my life with that ring
when you didn't get the high school ring
it was just really broke my heart
and I just thought he just didn't care
enough about it about me and what came
of that well
not a whole lot whose fault was that no
that was probably mine
look at y'all and I made all of the
dresses Eddie set his sights High
joining ROTC at the University of
Tennessee in Knoxville with dreams of
flying planes in the U.S Air Force it
was her senior year in high school and
Eddie couldn't find the words to tell a
proper goodbye to Caroline so he didn't
we pulled up in her driveway and I said
may I kiss you
and so I kissed her good night then
not knowing that that's the last time I
would kiss her in 64 or 65 years and I
got out of that car and ran up the steps
and slammed the door and went upstairs
and cried all night
that was it their lives would follow far
different paths she became Miss
Nashville
1959 two years later they were married
to other people she to Charles Wallace
he to Polly Piper Eddie would go on to
serve 21 years flying kc-135s for the
United States Air Force
Caroline traveled the world she was an
interior designer a magazine writer and
wrote three novels
things changed in December 2021 Eddie's
wife Polly the mother of their two
children died from ALS Lou Gehrig's
Disease they'd been married two days shy
of 60 years I heard you were her
caretaker yes I was for about a year and
a half to two years it's just a
shows you his strength and how sweet and
kind and gentle this man is after her
marriage to Charles Wallace ended in the
80s Caroline married a man named George
Kennedy he died in 2001. over the course
of your life did you wonder how Eddie
was all the time
all the time Eddie did you wonder how
she was yes I did in April 2022 Eddie
was living in California Caroline in
Nashville and all at once something hits
me I said
I've got to call her I had nine calls
and I don't answer on solicited calls
Eddie you called nine times nine times
I'm not gonna give up I love it yeah not
gonna give up just what she wanted to
hear that third night he told me he
still loved me
and
I knew my life had changed he flew to
Nashville to see her this time she was
in the driver's seat and I heard you
didn't make it too far from the airport
no no no he peeked his head into my car
and I just
My Breath Away
I've never seen anything like it in my
entire life
I just can't even explain it so I got
out of the parking lot zoom zoom zoom
went around and found the FedEx parking
lot and it was the warehouse it was
closed at night and had all these
security lights and I got out and jumped
around and we hugged and kissed and I
remember looking up at the security
lights and insects were swirling all
around the FedEx lights
wow so FedEx does deliver
at the age of 84 Eddie popped the
question he said well we'll get you a
ring and I said no
this is what I want
and he put this on my finger and that's
his high school class ring that you
wanted 60 years ago
it's my engagement ring and the girl got
it yeah
yeah I love you
her Dream came true if you had to title
your story what would it be miraculous
that we found our love again
we asked God all the time
why did you do this and now we know to
take care of each other and believe it
or not the two lovebirds have discussed
life after death and Caroline tells us
that Eddie will be buried next to Polly
that's the way that she wants it she
says that's the mother of his two kids
wow and that's where he should be she's
going to be buried in the family plot
back in Nashville God I love them both I
mean just the way that they came
together but what so touches me so is
that you can feel this kind of passion
at this stage at this time in your life
I love this story David yours just melt
away yeah time disappears when they're
together and they're making out like
kids at the FedEx parking lot I love
birds in their Eddies by the way
Caroline has a birthday on Thursday
Happy Birthday I just love that you can
still
go back to that love that you felt
burning 60 some odd years ago and you
asked a question I was wondering did
they think about each other during that
the times that they were with other
people and they did and I just
appreciated how deferential she has been
to poly like she honors what Polly was
in his life for 60 years right and she
recognizes that it wasn't meant to be
that they were together back then but
today in the end
you guys wonder if your high school
Sweetheart's thinking about you does it
uh
I think is it just me oh well that's my
my follow-up question I think we gotta
go to commercial break right now
Nate and I are in the middle of life's
journey and we were happily married
individual okay well all right Gail did
you have a high school sweetheart I did
do you think about him
sometimes but not like that not the way
that they're thinking I just wonder I
wonder how he's doing oh he's not the
way they're yeah not the way that
they're clearly still pining for each
other which is nice no planning okay
it's a no pining okay got it
David thank you very much